[Musique]
quand ils ont eu cette idée de graves
viennent ils ont eu neuf sollicité assez
rapidement parce qu'ils pensaient que ça
pourrait être sympa pour pour dans le
circuit de passer par ici et de faire
découvrir l'exploitation aux différents
partis tout temps et c'est tout
naturellement qu'on a accepté puis
d'accueillir aussi le courage de
tellement c'était assez sympa je suis
allé voir c'est sympa bon ça c'est que
cette ville bruxelles pour faire à
manger en bien de faire des trucs comme
ça
des trucs nouveaux dordor on est livré à
soi marque il faut chercher de quoi
manger il faut se débrouiller
d'accord c'est bien alors vous allez
goûter les produits l'a déjà de la ferme
38 rue des bons enfants du club font mal
c'est une exploitation agricole avec
la fabrication de fromages du célèbre le
dernier donc voilà on a 160 chèvre avec
lesquels on produit du lait la totalité
du lait qu'on produit est transformé en
sont âgées entre sa mère ses deux jeunes
enfants pourtant en circuit court donc à
la fois la ferme sur les marchés mais
également avec quelques magasins
supérette mais les producteurs
là ça leur laisse moins s'ils sont assez
critiques sur lie la première fois que
je roule en manches courtes
voilà un petit mot pour les suivants
l'approuver faut leur dire quoi arrêter
tout faux continuent et vont continuer à
tisser folk mais il faut avoir de la
patience
et puis c'est quand même bien découvrir
aussi pour vous surtout les paysages ont
le nez dans le guidon il ya vraiment
choisi
[Musique]